before we get started I've got to tell
you about three great companies pick
click is the first it's a one-person
startup from my friend Ryan in San Diego
pick click gives you a visual way to
search ebay Etsy and other sites Ryan is
already doing 1,000,000 product sales
per month on pitt klick com not hits but
sales go to p iccl IC ke kaam to see how
he's doing it 99designs it's the largest
crowd source marketplace for graphic
design when I use them I wrote a
description at the design I needed and
how much I wanted to pay I got a bunch
of designs back I gave each designer
feedback and picked the one I liked best
and that's the only one that I paid for
try them for logo design if you need a
blog design use them if you need I app
icons use them there's so many different
reasons why you might want to use them
check out 99designs and you'll see why
so many past mixergy guests have be used
99designs calm and grasshopper I've had
them now as my longest sponsor for a
reason not only do my does my audience
love them but you might have heard
several guests here on mixergy say that
they use grasshopper calm as a result of
these messages and they love it it's the
virtual phone system that entrepreneurs
like me love because it offers us
multiple extensions music on hold call
forwarding it makes you just it gives an
impression of having a big professional
organization but also caters to your
need to travel and to be flexible check
out grasshopper calm there's program hey
everyone it's andrew warner founder of
mixer GECOM home of the ambitious
upstart I've got with me today Salman
Khan he is the founder of well an online
school that's launched and run largely
through YouTube do I have that right
yeah it's well it's known mainly for the
video library on YouTube right now
there's 1,500 videos it is being used
it's at over 16 million views 200,000
unique users a month it is definitely
the most used education platform on on
YouTube and as far as I can tell looking
at the other open course initiatives the
most used library on the web right now I
went to the courses in preparation for
this interview and I
saw that you teach math basic math you
say you started out teaching one plus
one equals two I got so into a history
course that I almost stopped almost
stopped working and I said Andrew you
can't do this so you know what i did i
used this program called zamzar that's
gonna rip your course it's going to put
it on my iPhone I'm going over to to an
Estancia here this weekend on the ride
over I'm gonna be watching you teach me
history was that freakin fascinating oh
cool no glad and that's it that's
actually really good feedback because I
get a lot of there's a lot of
interesting discussion about how
credentials someone should be the
teacher certain subject and most of my
credentials are in computer science and
in finance and and and and and math and
and I I did the history I love history
but I i did that want to kind of push
push push the boundaries it to show that
you know you don't have to necessarily
have a PhD you just have to have a
passion for the subject so I'm glad to
hear that in and you hopefully won't
have to rip it soon it'll be on iTunes
up by the end of the summer it'll be an
itunes you all the entire Khan Academy
library I'm going to come back to that
point you said you don't have to have a
PhD I want to ask you about about what
qualifies you to teach all these
subjects because you're teaching more
and more of them you've got a course on
IPOs work on how rate how to raise money
for start-up all that let me start off
by asking you a question that I ask a
lot of my other guests here how much
money does the Khan Academy make well
that answer could be it could be
answered on a bunch of different levels
up it is a not-for-profit that's a
decision we can talk about because there
was a kind of a thought process i was
being approached by some people in the
venture capital and the entrepreneurial
world about starting it is kind of a
social for profit venture or a pure for
profit venture a little bit of both but
it is a pure not-for-profit and there's
a little bit of advertising that comes
in it goes to the not-for-profit and
we're being very delicate about the
advertising not too aggressive there and
when i quit my job as a hedge fund
analyst in September I was making
nothing so it was essentially living off
the savings and very little at me patent
I'm sorry I fairly should go to cut out
when you when right after you explain
that you quit your job as a hedge fund
analyst and then you can you pick it up
from there oh yeah so
after the after I quit I was living off
of savings until about I would say about
a month ago where we've gotten some
fairly significant donations so now i
can at least take a salary to do this
you know not a hedge fund salary but a
salary okay um and the donations are
coming from people who are hitting that
donate donate button on top of your
website well yeah there's a ton of
people who are hitting that little
paypal donation you know and that's
anywhere from I've gotten donations as
little as you know 50 Cent's all the way
but there's a lot of people who just
donate unsolicited 100 200 300 500 I've
even got a couple of that root of two
three thousand just from that paypal
donation button but more recently we've
got some pretty significant checks from
people out here in the valley that have
you know Oh get us to the point that i
have run way to have a salary for at
least you know several years and
obviously we will be other opportunities
to backfill from there what kind of
people there um you know I there a
couple of couple of them are venture
capitalists in this area one gentleman
he's uh he's up actually is non values
in Europe he's a pretty prominent
businessman in Europe there's another I
mean a lot of the people are people in
the tech space you know and they're not
doing is and investments obviously it's
not for profit but I think they're
excited about the potential year the
potential for kind of disrupting and I
think the feedback I guess for a lot of
them is look a lot of people are doing
this a lot of people have talked about
doing this type of thing it's kind of an
obvious idea take videos from good
instructors put them on the web and
eventually do some analytics around it
do some self-paced learning and
everything's going to be great but no
one's really done it you know that the
best today outside of Khan Academy is is
the open courseware efforts at you know
MIT and Stanford and all that and that's
essentially just been videos and
classrooms and lowering it can I say you
can say it and you know I feel this I'm
a huge consumer of their OpenCourseWare
but you have to be really motivated and
sit through a lot of things that you
don't necessarily want to pay attention
to get to what you want and sometimes
it's delivered well sometimes it's not
it's kind of inconsistent quality and
there's all sorts of other things that
occur when you have a video camera in a
classroom that make it a little bit
weird
but uh yeah I think I think they
appreciate the fact that Khan Academy is
you know 99 percent execution and you
know one percent talk we ask you this
then I've got your resume here I
actually went to uh to the Wayback
Machine to see what you were up to
before you did this to see who you were
and you had your resume up and i'm
looking at a freakin impressive in
addition to three degrees from MIT which
a lot of us have seen in new stories
about you and the one from Harvard you
worked at Oracle you worked in a venture
capital firm you work for you were on a
path to be one of the one of these rich
people of Silicon Valley you're not
gonna be that now right not to be didn't
know yeah unless unless the unless they
make a movie about the Khan Academy the
yeah you know it's it's funny when I was
working at a hedge but you know my the
six years after business school I was I
was a senior analyst at a hedge fund and
it was doing well and then my manager
retired he encouraged me to start my own
but so I was on that track to to kind of
be a hedge fund manager and all that and
but but the whole time I kind of
rationalized that the only reason why
I'm doing this is because I want a one
day starter school and in my mind I
didn't want to start a school you know
write grants and go to the Department of
Education and get a charter and all of
that and I felt it would constrain me
too much as like no I just want to
become really rich and just do it on my
own terms so that was my rationalization
for just trying to generate alpha day
and night but you know as the Khan
Academy story goes I kind of got an
outlet for some of my ideas with my
cousin's tutoring them virtually and
then the youtube thing took off I
orbital software app a lot of people are
using that and a lot of the visions
started to become concrete a lot sooner
than I had expected it to and and there
is just kind of a little bit of
introspection realizing that I got a lot
more satisfaction out of yeah you know
the hedge fund job is is it is a great
job even irrespective of how much they
may or may not compensate you but this
was just ten times more fun just the
impact the you know almost you know
everything i did on a daily basis it
kind of added to this library that could
be around forever my son who's 15 months
old right now could use it when he when
he's 18 or 30 or whatever
so that idea got really exciting and you
know just me think about it and you see
people in the valley like this I mean
and I think Silicon Valley is an
interest quiz because you do see this it
really isn't about money I think so many
people they view the money as points and
they view it as kind of a you know how
important was my contribution to the
world and I think with Kahn Academy I
get to do that without having to play
the whole you know a you know venture
back start-up game and and what's
interesting about Khan Academy is even
though it's not going to make me any
money and I'm not gonna you know be able
to buy a nice house in Atherton and all
that type of thing in terms of just
impact it is already you know kind of
it's gettin it's gettin more notoriety
than many already you know fairly
successful start right up the startup
world and ahead and exit for you know
ten or twenty million dollars that's a
huge win with those type of things are a
dime a dozen out of the valley and in
the Khan Academy it's not like I'm you
know that's mine but the Khan Academy I
already feel has more impact than a lot
of these you know whatever you need this
is so from that point it was just way
more in fact way more fun you know every
day the things that I was contributing I
felt it was is contributing to kind of a
lasting legacy and you know just just
the letters you get from people i mean
this was also another realization when
you work when you work at a firm kind of
the best thing that could happen to you
is kind of a pat on the back from the
boss or a nice bonus but in this I'm
getting letters like 20 or 30 a day and
these letters are you know some of them
are just thank you but some of them are
like I was going to fail algebra until I
started using these videos or now I want
to be an engineer and I thought it was
bad at math my whole life so when you
when you get stuff like that it really
makes say you know this is this is what
I want to do how about this i saw one
letter on your website someone said that
i don't know where she was or where he
was but the letter went where I live
black kids don't really have access to
schools and my mother moved me so I have
more opportunities and my teachers
weren't doing it for me and then i
discovered your videos essentially that
was a story and things changed ya know
in that letter i actually put on my
website I view that as the letter that
on some level convinced me to really
quit my job I mean there were
other moments over the last you know I
would say over the last three years
where you know Khan Academy I got a
letter or something like that and I see
no you know maybe I'll do this full time
or take time off from the hedge fund
world and then I look at my finance and
say no no I may be able to do the hedge
fund rolling longer but then I got a
letter in August late August of 09 and I
got that letter in the same week that
the Khan Academy had gotten some
notoriety from the tech museum that the
Microsoft Tech award and it was getting
a little press and I just kind of viewed
as a confluence of events that were
telling me that I should be doing this
but but I got that letter especially I
mean I still think to date that's
probably one of the top definitely top
five letters that I've gotten I mean
that you know it's on the level of this
without me really doing anything
incremental for that person they just
consume these videos over summer it
really changed their life by the way
people in the chat room are just they're
so inspired I see danblank saying this
guy's really inspiring we're only ten
minutes into the interview and he's
already inspired he says such strong
integrity from Joseph Jack's everybody
here they're just loving it holy crap
from Joseph Jack's about your three MIT
degrees so you blown us away let's do
the way you know and i'll add that i'll
add this is another kind of thing about
the about making it nonprofit here is
that the goodwill that comes out from
this is just you know orders of
magnitude greater than anything I mean
I'm commiss if I did as a for-profit it
wouldn't have had the same level of
goodwill and there's all order we could
talk more about it in general but you
know I think I think people respond well
to it and so people are coming out of
the woodwork to really help as well sees
what I'd like to do I'd like to ask you
about your vision long term so i could
continue to be inspired inspired and
inspire my audience I want to find out
how you got here and then I want to ask
you how to do it so well because you're
able to to take subjects that you didn't
spend your whole life learning but
somehow you make it seem like they're
part of who you are and then you explain
them in an easy-to-understand way and I
want to learn how you do that so let's
go let's start off with the big vision
so we know where you're going with this
what do you envision in the future
coming out of this yeah well you know
that people know about the videos I'm
going to keep making videos there's
probably the highest return on my time
you know I was talking to a foundation
yesterday they're like
what do you envision yourself in five
years I spent at least sixty percent my
time is still going to make videos
there's an infinite amount of knowledge
as you know I've I teach things that are
not necessarily in my core expertise but
I make them part of my corporate
expertise so I can teach them but but
beyond just the video library I I see it
becoming a free virtual school and what
I think that entails is you have a video
library you have self-paced adaptive
exercise you don't need calm adaptive if
you like that's already built actually
started building that before I started
working on the videos the videos are
actually a compliment to the software
piece and people can login instead con
exercises appspot com and it's all free
it's need a Google accounts on App
Engine and people started coming out of
the women start working on that so it's
an open source project on top of that so
you know it not only will Khan Academy
be in a virtual school but that code can
then be used for anyone else if they
want to make their own island of
Education if they want but the idea is
you have the videos you have exercised
that start you with one plus one equals
two work you all the way up and they're
dynamically generated work you all the
way up you know right now they go
through about algebra the videos go well
beyond that but the exercise I want them
to go through calculus and chemistry and
those to get keep building out and we
collect data on everything we know what
videos you watched when you've watched
the videos what exercise you've watched
oh you know we will do heuristics on
when you're stuck and then what I think
we kind of complete the pictures of
virtual school is it you know leverage
the community who do actual peer to peer
instruction so if I know that Andrew is
having trouble with negative exponents
and Sal who lives in Mountain View knows
negative exponents and I know both of
your schedules I'll set up a
peer-to-peer interaction and then you
and I will have a session not too
different than I was having with my
cousins four years ago and then we'll
also record it so it also becomes part
of this library and we can collect all
of this data around was that a good
interaction I'll rape you you'll write
me and then we can also see where
there's two statistically significant
outcomes on your performance and I think
there's a lot to be said you know in the
for-profit world there's a lot of people
doing video libraries and they're doing
different ways to collect data on it and
have the best videos then there are
other people are doing exercises and
there are other people who are starting
to explore the peer-to-peer learning but
I'm pretty convinced in order to a prop
you want you want to have them all up
together in the same place okay so we
got the videos today you talked about
what you have up on App Engine I played
with that game for a little bit it's
interesting you get to learn and then
you go into a into a place where you
take quizzes based on what you've
learned so to use the the example that I
that I played with it was what's 9 plus
5 and if I didn't know the answer I
could press the button to see a hint and
they hain't he showed me balls
underneath 9 and then I still didn't
know the answer that I would hit the
hint again and I'd see five balls under
5 and then I could answer it and you
keep track of it so you've got that
today and in the future you're gonna add
peer-to-peer and you mentioned that
there are other people who are already
doing this what about people like
cramster who's doing this already or who
else who try interview here I
interviewed the founder of University of
the people shy he wants to create an
online University how does this fit in
with what's already out there um you
know I think a lot of the focus so far
has been on platform and I'm not a
hundred percent you know I'm somewhat
familiar with both of those two efforts
you've had and I think in order to make
these work platform matters but the
platform really has to have a core
really good content and that's what's
going to make people use the platform
and I think you know right now the value
proposition and I think the reason why
Khan Academy has a lot of traction is
because it has you know when people say
what does Khan Academy it's ninety-five
percent content and five percent
platform but I think that's what gives
us the ability to eventually turned into
ninety-five percent platform maybe fifty
fifty fifty percent platform so I don't
know what these what these other efforts
are but I have you know I've even
advised a few startups in the valley
about you know education that and you
know what without trying to be too blunt
about it I think a lot of their problem
is that you know they're a couple of
MBAs they have this big picture idea
which is not a correct idea but they but
but i think they downplay the value of
good instruction or they downplay the
value of really good content which i
think is super important in education
alright let's go back to how you started
this I feel like I've I I feel like
everyone probably knows it already but
they can't possibly can you tell people
the reason i feel that is because late
in our space in the entrepreneurial
space people keep talking about you like
I saw you on hacker news I saw your
story on Jason freed site of course a
lot of us are NPR nerds we heard your
story there for anyone who didn't hear
how it started can you tell him yeah I
was um well it depends how early you
want to go I mean if you go back to
college oh I always did have this vision
of kind of creating a holy grail of at
the time I thought would be like a
software-based education platform then
obviously my education got my career got
derailed and a hedge fund we're in 2004
now my my cousin and uncle and aunt were
visiting me from New Orleans my cousin
nadia was having trouble well this came
up in conversation that she was not
placed into pre algebra for seventh
grade and then I cousin hey you know
that's a big deal you don't realize it
it seems like a harmless thing in middle
school but then she's not going to take
algebra and 8th grade she's not gonna
take calculus when she's a senior and
that's going to really limit her career
opportunities or if she wants all of
these other byproducts and even her own
self-confidence so and she's a really
bright girl she was a really bright girl
then he was pretty obvious so I made a
deal with I was like hey if you are
willing to work with me half an hour a
day after your school in my work
opportunity remotely I'll be in boston
you'll be in New Orleans and she agreed
and we we started doing it and you know
we just used yahoo doodle and and a
conference call and it ended up working
out really well I mean even within a
couple of months she not only done
pre-algebra she was working on algebra
stuff and then guys are working with her
brothers and then other family members
and family friends and you know a couple
things popping like well you know I you
know one-on-one teaching people really
works even if its virtual which is kind
of might be kind of obvious by sexy I
wish there's a way that I could make
this scale a little bit or minimum make
it a little bit easier for me to
logistically handle everything that I'm
doing and so I did two things I started
working on the software i started doing
that before the videos because i wanted
you know when i start tutoring even na
VI would pointed to random websites and
i'd say hey there's some exercises there
i wanted to play around with them and i
didn't know what she did when she did
the exercise i was very date a focus and
I was like well I have to take her word
for it how she felt about it so I keep
pointer different things I don't let me
just write my own little my only my own
little JavaScript scripts to generate
problems
let me put a little database behind it
so I can track when she's doing it how
long is taking her all of that type of
thing and then a buddy literally said
hey you know why don't you why'd you add
some videos there because I was kind of
telling them about yeah you know these
kid you know I keep having to do the
same lecture over again it's getting
hard to schedule I have you know five or
ten kids that I'm working with and half
a day job is that why you make youtube
videos might be useful form and so I
tried it out and and you know the
initial feedback I got from my cousin's
was that they like me better on youtube
then then in person or virtually or gif
or alive and and i think that the
takeaway was is that it was less stress
they could pause and repeat they could
do it on their own time there was none
of this scheduling situation so I got
that feedback from them other people
started watching the videos and other
people started sending these notes like
hey I got an a on my algebra exam
because of this and it's person I've
been one note a week or one note a month
but it got me pretty excited and the
idea started to crystallize that gee if
I make this library even if it's just
useful to my family like my cousins who
are using it now and my I didn't have a
son at the time but my future kids and
anyone that's like just a huge you know
gift to our family and if other people
end up using it that's even more meat so
it kind of became a fun outlet for me I
was working you know we had moved out to
Palo Alto a year after that it's all
working east coast hours I was done with
work by about 2 p.m. my wife was in
medical residency so I had a lot of time
and as this is a fun use of my time and
it was kind of an outlet for me to get
this kind of education these educational
ideas off my plate and I love
mathematics it was also a way to engage
parts of my brain that I hadn't engaged
in a while so it was just a lot of fun
and it was actually having an impact so
and then fast forward four years you
know at September 2009 and take it from
there and then you know now we have you
know whatever 16 17 million views and
it's the most used open course library
September 2009 being the day you quit
being the month you quit your work so
that you can do this right I'm right you
know what I'm wondering is as you're
saying this if I had a relative one to
learn math or wanted to learn anything I
might help them once and then after that
I might refer them to a website where
they can go and learn after that why
would you why would you spend so much
time
now you've got a job you've got other
things going on well you know I think
it's um you know it was fun I think well
you know look if you work at a hedge
fund it was a great job and I have to
say you know the hedge funds I work for
and I worked for one pitch one in
particular for six years it wasn't the
typical like you know really high power
type a thai place it was a really
intellectual thoughtful type of firm my
boss was a really great guy really
focused on kind of work-life balance but
at the same time you know it was a
really good job but there wasn't a lot
that you could say what am I contributed
to the world today and and even the hit
the nature of the hitch fun job itself
you could do a really good analysis and
that investment goes nowhere and then
you could get lucky and you could do so
that there's a lot of that and so that
your your you almost crave for something
that you do every day where you feel
like I did this for X hours and that X
ours was a positive contribution to
something it made the pie a little bit
bigger and I think that's what it you
know it gave me a little bit of purpose
and it gave me an outlet and made me
feel like I wasn't you know you know I
talked to a lot of my friends for
roughly at my stage in my career I was
like you know it kind of dawned on me
that look you know your life is pretty
valuable and what I was doing at the
hedge fund yeah and I don't want it to
me I mean I think it's a great job but
you know I spent six years of my life
but really what I had to show for it was
I had experience I learned to analyze
securities better and I've saw a lot
about how businesses work and all that
but what I really had to show for it was
just some numbers in a in a bank account
someplace like I really had no actual
tangible contribution to show for it and
this gave me that outlet where I felt
like these years weren't wasted and I
and I and I feel that more and more you
know when I every day I almost feel like
my day is wasted if I don't make a few
videos or if I don't write a little bit
of software if I just did the whole day
in meetings or if I'm if I'm trying to
fundraise or whatever else I feel like
I'm not doing what the kind of guy to me
is supposed to be doing did you think at
the time that this might help you
prepare for the school you'll launch
someday or did you think that maybe this
would lead to a school or software that
i can create and sell what do you think
was going to lead to when once once it
got to about what what's the the job you
know what the JavaScript modules once
had about I would say about 20 of them
and it was you know and oh and i was
using with my cousins and family friends
and they were using and it really was
teaching them and then one and you
combine it with the videos almost a
video library got about 100 and the
combination of it really was pretty good
at teaching people pre-algebra through
algebra i started think very seriously
you know what the school of the future
needs to have something like this as its
operating system used to have something
like this at its DNA so i i i did an
actually I do view this virtual school
that I you know that we talked about
earlier as it is a virtual school it
could stand on itself people can go to
that virtual school and use it to learn
things independent of anything else but
it can also be used as as the operating
system or the DNA for a physical school
where you have a one-room schoolhouse
kids of all ages you know you don't it's
actually a very bizarre way that people
connect age with different concepts so
you have students of all ages in a room
together they're working on for part of
their day not their full day for part of
their today they're using technology to
kind of get their core skills going if
they don't understand something there
are other people in the room they're
going to help them so you have a lot of
peer-to-peer occurring in the room it
could even occur across site and then
the rest of the day is spent doing real
project based learning there's a lot of
talk about project-based learning but
not not much of it is substantive I mean
real product basically was no kids are
actually learning a program like they're
really working building things they're
actually they're actually writing things
that are being published they're
actually a composing music instead of
just learning to play music so so that's
the whole aspect so I I definitely I
definitely wanted this to become
eventually the and it is it does seem
like it is becoming the DNA of a
possible framework in school I you know
I did it with a couple of summer camps
and the teachers wanted reports can i
see you know all the students where they
are and we pretty quickly settled on a
kind of a paradigm where the teacher
would walk into the room all the kids
are working at their own pace and the
teacher just gets a spreadsheet saying
look everyone's fine but those two kids
are having trouble with negative adding
and subtracting negative numbers and so
instead of the teacher giving a lecture
and all of that type of stuff and admit
the teacher just takes those two kids
aside does a very intimate session with
them and let everyone else work at their
own pace and
and we're the next to people who need
help and you can even before the teacher
even gets involved you could have other
peers help and all that type of thing so
and you get more and more technology and
you can get more and more data on it you
can make everyone's life a lot more
streamlined and be able to do much more
intelligent things on on where you where
you point people's energies I could so
see the passion as you talk about this I
can't imagine you would dispassionate
about hedge funds or venture capital or
or any the previous work ya know I was
you are I mean I guess now that i'm not
working in those industries i can say it
i guess you have to you know i don't
know i mean those those were yeah i mean
III think outside of the Khan Academy my
job as a hedge fund was probably the
best possible possible job what was fun
about it you mentioned earlier I like to
I teach out of my core competency so a
lot of what I do is I really learned new
things and I try to learn it a really
deep level and that's really what I have
to do with my hedge fund job where you
know every day we talked to an oil
company the next thing we talked to a
you know an internet marketing company
in the next day we talked to a you know
we talked to a chicken egg company so so
it was this kind of process if you're
always learning new things and you have
to kind of become a quick expert I see
um alright so you get these videos
online I understand how today when you
have how many videos we have we're a
little over 1,500 a little over 1,500 I
understand when you get to even five
hundred to a thousand videos it starts
to feel like something when NPR comes in
interviews you when the BBC has you on
starts to feel like something what about
when it was just a hundred or 200 do you
ever feel at those moments wow just a
YouTube producer to me and the guy was
creating the cat videos and he's got
more viewers than I do oh yeah no
absolutely i mean you know yeah i think
in the past year a lot of friends and
family are saying hey yeah what Sal's
doing is great but I think if you go
back three four years ago and I was kind
of just going into the you know that
sometimes the guest room and eventually
converted closet making these YouTube
videos um you know Eliza what what Sal
doing why is he spending all of his time
doing this I had a lot of friends and
kind of like you know this is kind of
weird what he's um tell me about know
that felt because it's easy to look back
and say hey you know that's what
happened and we got through it tell me
about how that felt so that when I
have that situation in my life for one
of our listeners has it in their lives
where they're just like a hundred videos
into a million video project the way you
were back then and no one no one
believes in them and they doubt
themselves they can identify with you so
what was it like for you well you know I
think what was what allowed me to kind
of keep up a high level of energy and
stay motivated and want to do it is that
I didn't care if it if it ever got to
where it did get um I was pretty happy
with the you know I guess you call him
small successes I was excited that 20
people a day we're watching 20 people
who I didn't know we're learning math
for me and the idea that even if I were
to get hit by a bus 20 people a day even
if it didn't grow it all would still
learn math for me that to me was a
pretty profound concept and so for me
you know just a couple of notes a day
and and that idea were enough for me to
say hey this is this is a project worth
my time I mean it is you know if at
minimum no one I you know no
non-relatives watch it but if my son
when he's 18 years old is able to learn
a little bit of algebra or calculus from
me that by itself makes it worth it I
mean that by itself makes it a neat
project and so I think in those early
days I was just I was excited about the
small the the you know that small impact
that that that was enough now and in the
back of my mind it was growing I said
well if it keeps growing at this rate
then you know right now there's 20 next
month or might be 30 and boy in a year
we'd have a couple thousand and two year
you know exponential growth it happens
pretty fast and so that I was like that
would that just be gravy on top of
everything else that happened did you
have a moment where you doubted it were
you were you were down on it where you
said what am I doing here in the closet
are on my computer wherever it was you
know I never did although I did have a
lot of um I did have I never doubted it
and I'll tell you one of the you know
I'm a bit of a stubborn character and
and I did early on have people say who
do you think you are like you know I've
had friends who are school teachers who
are academics and not all of them some
of them were very supportive they
thought it was cool and in general I got
kind of a negative pushback from people
who never experienced the videos i think
there's there's two camps people who try
to
to experience the videos that wow this
is kind of a cool way to learn and it
was strangely engaging and strangely
addictive and it kind of got me excited
about things it was kind of entertaining
and those people were almost universally
supportive but very but a very small
subset of my people who are close to me
actually did that they actually actually
took the time to experience them a lot
more people I know or like you know
there's billions of dollars being spent
on education there's thousands of people
with PhDs spending their whole life on
fixing the education system is it an
arrogant of you to think that you and
your YouTube videos are going to have
any type of impact I mean that's
essentially the summary of what a lot of
people would tell me and you know I
would defend it a little bit at first
and be like well I mean in the back of
my mind I would say well a lot of I
think a lot of those efforts they're
just spent on bureaucracies and people
talking about things that but I wouldn't
say that you know my response well you
know you're right I don't think it's
gonna you know I just want to do my own
little small thing and if it has any
impact it has any impact but in the back
of my mind it made me really angry they
motivated me even more to to do to make
more and better videos and to do it in
you know and to some degree that's what
like like the history videos you're
talking you know every time I made a
small a small set of videos you know I
started pre-algebra algebra i always get
some push oh yeah that's nice and cute
what you have there but this won't work
for for calculus or this won't work for
differential equations and or physics
and i'm doing mom you know you may be
right but then I'd go home and say I'm
gonna show that person I'm going to pick
some calculus and differential II and
then and then you know then you
immediately get the pushback oh well you
know this might work for that but it
won't work for Humanities it won't work
you know and you won't be able to do
that you're gonna have to get other
people I mean it's amazing how many
people still tell me so you're going to
have to get more people I mean and I'm
open to it I'm not like a guest getting
other in fact when I started I thought
that's how this would happen that there
would be 20 of us doing a large but it
was actually hard to a lot of people
would say yeah that's awesome at parties
if you like yeah I want to make videos
and that would be that'd be so cool but
it actually comes down actually sitting
down with the tablet and recording
youtube videos no one really did it and
so even now there's a lot of assumption
of like oh well you're you're not
be able to do all of K through 12 and
I'm like what part time for four years
you know I was working in the hedge fund
most of the time it's pretty much ninety
percent of K through 12 math has been
done and you extrapolate that full time
it's not going to take long to do and
I'm not going to say that you know I'm
the only person I actually want other
people to do this but they're not doing
it so if they're not doing it and I want
to do it anyway so I'm going to do it so
you know it is a bit of a motivating
force when people kind of question your
validity or your ability to execute on
something I think it ignites a fire in
the belly a little bit haha I've seen
that I felt that in myself too um all
right so how do you do it how do you do
it so well let me just actually why
don't you start out by describing it
maybe I should have done that earlier in
the interview but I think but when we
start out with you describing it first
yeah you know the videos you don't see
me there black background almost
universally some of them don't have
black backgrounds but they have black
backgrounds and I'm just writing in
colors that I think look nice while I
talk while I married the video and the
form factor inna started to things this
was essentially what not he was
experiencing when i was doing those
initial live virtual sessions with her
she didn't see me we just had a
conference call going and she we did she
saw what I was writing and so it worked
with her site said that'll probably work
and I also wanted it to I I didn't have
good recording equipment I didn't have a
video camera and even if I did you know
I even thought about at one point maybe
buying one but it's really difficult if
even if you get a nice video camera you
have to get your lighting right then you
have to get your own microphone I mean
all sorts of crazy things you have to do
to make it look professional but if you
do just to a screen capture with a USB
headset and you know I start with
Microsoft Paint and now i'm using little
fancier stuff but it's all that i'm
still using you know smooth the drop
three it's a piece of freeware it comes
off a lot better and I and the feedback
I get from people and it's kind of
obvious is it now in hindsight is it's
actually much more intimate form factor
it doesn't feel like I'm on the other
side of a room lecturing to you it
literally feels like we're either beside
each other and we're looking at the same
blackboard or the same piece of paper or
it even feels like I'm you know what my
narration is your thoughts on some level
um and and so yeah you know I think the
and also the form factor both i think is
compelling to a lot of students and it's
really easy for me i literally just have
to press record rescue you know start
the screen capture going i don't have to
comb my hair i don't have to shave i
don't have to do anything and I just
start talking and start teaching and you
know the question of how I do with
things like a lot of the algebra content
a lot of you know what I do i do a lot
of that real-time very conversational a
lot of the example problems i do I in
the early videos actually made them up
on the fly which I realized is you know
that kind of waste a little bit of time
but i always do them on the fly and and
and i think that gives students a lens
into into concepts that they don't
normally see i mean in the textbook or a
traditional lecture you always have a
finished product that the teacher is
seeing the example they've done the
example maybe they have done it six
times that day for the last 20 years and
you never see them that you ever see the
art of the problem and you never see
solve in real time and i get a lot of
feedback teeth students like to see me
go down a little path and say oh a way
that's not right but you know i did it
because it looked like that but let me
let me back up and go down this other
path so so they really appreciate that
informal conversational kind of thinking
out loud style um for the more kind of
preparation intensive topics like you
know and I did cellular respiration or
you know the French Revolution I mean
these aren't things that night I was
exposed to them in my education but they
weren't something that I would like if
you had bumped into me two years ago and
said say I'll tell me everything about
tell me how many ATP's are generated by
the stage of cellular respiration I
would have been like well I took it a
long time ago what so those type of
things I do spend a lot of time
immersing myself in the subjects enemies
out that tell me about the process how
do you absorb that knowledge and then
we'll get into how do you how do you
share tough topic with someone else how
do you teach it how do you get the
knowledge in your head so quickly you
know it well it's um I try to I just
trying to read as many things as I can
and I think you know the way I to some
degree I don't know you know obviously
Khan Academy is dependent on the web you
needed YouTube and all that but it also
needed the web for my own preparation
because in kind of the old days you'd
only have one source you'd have your
textbook or whatever and that's a very
limiting but
how you literally you know you have
textbooks you have things like Wikipedia
you have random professors random people
on the web explaining concepts you know
ninety percent of them are explaining it
the same way but that ten percent
they'll say something and it just clicks
in your brain oh why didn't everyone
just say that that's the most and then
you have all these other you know I'm
actually a big fan of I think well this
is kind of a commentary in the
publishing industry I think text books
are written not to teach text books are
written to impress school boards and to
be these impressive weighty you know
tombs as opposed to something that a
student could digest I actually think a
lot of the you know whatever a teacher
self books that you get in the library
for ten dollars or the the you know
Barron's calculus ii all the easy way
biology these way these are actually
really good text like they shouldn't be
downplayed and you you start with
something like that and then when you
have questions you're like okay that
kind of gave me the overview but I still
don't know exactly what happens at this
stage or that stage then you can use
texts reference dig deeper use Wikipedia
as a reference and then when I really
get to some you know really core
question i was doing immunology which
i'm not an expert in and i was and and
you know and one part of my wife's
immunology textbook she she's a doctor
so she has her immunology textbook for
medical school and I was digging through
it in one part of it it was saying you
know B cells they need they need to be
they need to be exposed they need to be
exposed to the antigen to be activated
and another party says I will helper
t-cells activate b-cell science
questions like you know those both have
to happen or just one of that and I
couldn't find it anywhere i couldnt find
answer so I literally just called up a
friend who's a professor of biology at
Duke and I asked him I was like look I
know this is a really stupid question
you're going to judge me because you're
like who why does Sal I should be doing
immunology videos if I don't know the
answer this question and i asked him i
was like which one he's like oh that's
actually a very interesting question
there are certain types of b-cells and
it is like if you know it's an area of
research of why that is and this is that
it's completely not in the textbook and
so i think very quickly as long as
you're really kind of if you're asking
yourself the right questions and you
really are focused on getting down to a
distilled intuition of a subject it
doesn't take long before you can really
get to kind of fundamental questions
that even experts in the field say hey
that's an interest you know this is
another i talk to
lot of friends who have PhDs are
professors or doing pcs or whatever and
sometimes if I meet him at a party I'm
like oh yeah I'm going to do a video on
this probably next week and you know I
have this one question about that's like
a fundamental concept something that you
know first year grad student would
should know and they're like you know
what that's something I always wondered
but I really didn't have time to address
it in my education and I had qualifiers
to pass and I was probably embarrassed
to even bring it up inside of my
department and so I really don't know
the answer to that and one that makes me
feel a lot better but then we would kind
of become on a mission combined to get
that question answered and I would be
kind of their layperson that say hey
this guy is wandering out you know and
so I you know if you want to know you
kind of where I think I'm adding value
beyond people who have spent more time
in the field is that I have the luxury
of spending as much time as I want on
core concepts and I think core concepts
are the most important because that's
where you build your intuition of a
subject you know when i started in
chemistry before I even started I just
played with the periodic table for like
a week just to make sure I understood
the nuance why was it structured that
way why is the pattern but you know how
did the people hide it come about as
opposed to you know it's just there and
how do you interpret it you know how do
how did the first people even think of
making a periodic table and things like
that and I get that luxury and and PhDs
and grad students and professors don't
have that luxury of really understanding
court you know a friend of mine I'm done
quantum mechanics videos yet and I had a
friend whose explaining me a little bit
he's like all yeah if you have this you
have this electron it's moving in this
chamber sis theoretical chamber I was
like oh why is it moving why is it
changing direction and he's like it's a
good question I mean Slyke one of these
fundamental examples at every first-year
quantum mechanics student look urns and
they just the teacher doesn't go over
that and they just say all this they
give the equation you kind of learn to
mimic it and so on and so forth but no
one everyone's afraid to ask these very
basic questions I asked them I've in
should I get an answer to them and I
think when I teach it I'll answer those
questions and then people don't have
those gaps in their head it seems like
the Khan Academy is is great for
teaching con for teaching you because
you now are going through the ideal
University can you talk about how
knowing that you're going to teach what
you're learning affects what you're
learning how do ya well you know that it
puts the bar so much higher I mean I
think in most like I'm gonna start doing
organic chemistry soon and when you're
taking organic chemistry and I took
organic chemistry in college you know
your your goal is really to get an A and
if you're you know if you're specially
intellectually inspired maybe to get
another level of understanding but
there's all these other pressures that
are going on in college or grades and
social pressures and other classes and
all of that and you know now I know I'm
going to explain it and I know you know
from the math videos there's a certain
brand there's a certain standard that
people expect that I'm not just going to
throw something at you and say memorize
this or I'm not just going to say like
oh this is beyond you don't try to
understand it the the standard people
expect from me is that I will give them
an intuition and I will distill it down
into concept where people say always
that's obvious that's all that thing is
saying about the universe and so that's
the Senate I hold myself to when I learn
it so it doesn't take long actually to
learn something of a level where you can
get an a on most exams with most schools
but it's it's a it's a whole other level
where you're getting to the really deep
why is this intuitive or why does that
expression look the way it does or how
is it related to another expression and
so it's usually motivating while I'm
learning I mean it keeps me it keeps me
going a little bit deeper than I think
most most anyone what if they were just
doing it for the fur you know we're
getting a credential don't medical
schools teach by showing doing teaching
method where the student gets to learn
it gets to do it and then has to teach
it to someone else because when you
teach it you really absorb it ya know
and I'm a huge believer that I mean
that's you know what I talk about the
virtual school that's why I think the
peer-to-peer is huge I think mastery
comes not just from being able to a lot
of problems it really comes from that
exercise of teaching it and I found it
with my own experience but if you have
kids all over the world teaching each
other and that's why you have that one
room schoolhouse holds and I think
you're going to have a whole other level
of mastery that doesn't exist right now
alright so how do you teach how do you
teach tough topics teach us how to teach
because we're all gonna have to teach
our employees you're gonna have to teach
people who we work with we're gonna have
to teach others online
what do you know well I think there's a
couple of things here and you brought up
an interesting point just now when you
talk about teaching employees and
teaching other I'm actually advising
some tech companies where they want to
build con type applications on their
platform and this and that and at first
I was writing like traditional specs
like you would expect you know product
manager whoever would write a company I
was like this is silly I make youtube
videos why don't I just do YouTube specs
so I were literally just make a
screenshot and I would just explain what
the interaction should look like it's
ten times better so I think to a large
degree just the form factor it makes it
way better than if I were to write a
white paper write us back or even if i
were to sat at a whiteboard and you my
hands and faces you're trying so so one
I think the form factor of screen
capture with hand-drawn writing is
pretty powerful at it some people have
told me that cognitively just seeing
typing or seeing a PowerPoint
presentation doesn't really stimulate
the brain but seeing someone write
something out you know handwritten
actually does and I kind of feel like
that it's also easier for me to produce
but um beyond that I think there's you
know what I do is just get as
comfortable as you possibly can with the
subject and but once you get that
comfort don't don't script the video
make it as relaxing as possible have fun
while you're doing it there's actually a
gentleman who's going to start
translating some of the videos into or
do and you know my 1feedback he did some
great videos but I was like have more
fun like if energy carries over in a
voice especially when you don't see the
face you really have to have a lot of
energy in your voice and if you're not
having fun the student won't have fun
and so have fun be relaxed but you know
really know what you're talking about
like don't throw out buzzwords without
really knowing what is going on behind
it so if you're if you're at a company
you know I actually think with the way
Khan Academy teaches would actually be
ideal instead of white papers instead of
you know a lot of what goes on inside
side of companies to teach people how to
do things is just teach your peers and
teach it as it really is don't try to
look smart yourself by throwing out
those words that you don't necessarily
understand or or that you heard someone
else that you think is smart say just
say it and is down to earth of a style
as you can be frank if there's something
that you don't understand and I think
people will respond well to
what about the way that you give
background before you get into the
subject how do you do it you know um
well you know I I I think go through
this process of making fifty hundred
videos I've gotten very good at big
train of thought and I think a lot of
people when they teach they actually
closed down they actually shut off a lot
of their thoughts that would be maybe
embarrassing that like you know but when
I do a problem there is a little bit of
a neuron that remind yourself that a
negative times a negative is a positive
and maybe even remind yourself why that
is and remind yourself you know all of
these things while you're doing a
problem and I lay all that stuff out
there so even if you're watching the
vector calculus videos it's literally I
don't assume anything i'm literally
doing stream of consciousness every
thought that's going in my brain you're
actually getting on on paper so there's
you know there's no skip steps if you
will I think there's that I you know
before I do the video I do try to really
make sure I understand the big picture
really well and probably I think what
you're talking about where I give the
background that's me articulating the
big picture so I have a framework in my
head of what were you even doing I think
a lot of times in all subjects once you
start getting into it you almost forget
what you're doing in the first place and
while i'm doing i like to remind myself
what are we even doing like we're on
like you know we're on step 50 of this
equate what was the whole point to begin
with and so it's good to remind yourself
is good to remind yourself at the
beginning and it's not some artificial
teaching technique ancillary i'm
reminding myself you know i'm reminding
myself this is why we're doing this
problem right now and i think it's
valuable for the for the student i think
i think whatever keeps my energy level
up while I do the video will also keep
up the engagement in the energy level of
the person observing the video see if
people have to get that French
Revolution night I can recommend it
before I've even finished watching it
was so good you even gave us a little
bit of background and you said well uh
the French supported America an American
in the American Revolution I thought wow
I wouldn't have thought to include
something like that but it really does
help me understand what about what's
about to happen here it does it's a it's
a great reminder well how do you make it
feel interactive when it's just you and
it and it's not even your your face in
the video how do you make it feel like
you're you're engaging a person
um well you know I think there's a
couple of things I think once again you
know we talked about the form factor how
it looks but it's also the videos are an
average about 10 minutes these history
videos go a little bit longer than that
but I think because it's 10 minutes the
person goes into that video wanting that
video so it's not like they're getting a
90 minute lecture which may engage for
them for part of it I mean it's almost
like when you the act of click on video
is almost like asking a question like
tell me more about the French Revolution
Russia and so it's literally just
addressing that exact need you have
right there I think the other things you
know I think it's the form factor it's a
little bit of my tone I'm conversational
it's I mean literally the tone i use in
the video is not at all different than
the tone i'm using right now it's it's
not at all like a lecture the next step
and this price not that at all how many
of them do you do a day depends what I'm
doing when I was doing French Revolution
or you know I'm doing some of the more
complex biological you know biochemistry
type mechanisms then I'm lucky to be
able to do two or three today and
there's other things that are taking up
my time now which I'm trying to shut off
I mean running an organization well I'm
trying to automate as much of that as
possible but uh you know right now I'm
doing a lot of worked examples for the
Monterey Institute in algebra one worked
examples where they just gave me a bunch
of examples I said yeah I'll do it for
you as long as I could put them on Khan
Academy and these are literally just
algebra problems so I'm doing right now
about 10 videos a day for the out door
problems and who's this far for the
Monterey Monterey Institute of
Technology and education they got a
grant to build this course and this and
that and why this is another interesting
thing as you know going back to what we
talked about being a lot of people in
the world are talking about making open
video content available and we should
get good teachers to put stuff up and
we'll do all this analytics when it
comes to execution there's you know that
they have gotten this and and I told
them I was like look you know I don't
know what you're doing or how much were
you spending on it but whatever you're
spending on it you know I'm sure I'll be
able to do it for like a tenth of the
cost as long as you're willing to donate
it to Khan Academy and I think you're
going to find it more engaging because
it's not going to be scripted it's just
going to be and like all great we've
written all the pumpkin sending ships I
was like don't send me the scripts it'll
ruin it'll ruin everything that you know
is good about the Khan Academy and so
they sent it and you know I've you know
over you know 10 videos a day you're
very quickly you can churn out about a
hundred videos and you know not too long
and they'd be done and I think when they
probably started thought is this huge
grand project that'll let you be done a
couple weeks got one of the question
here and I wasn't sure if I should ask
it or not but I've got to ask it because
I think it's important you and your wife
you move to one of the most expensive
parts of the country are you living in
Northern California you're living around
people who are who are making tons of
cash I gotta believe you've got some
expectation of lifestyle and your wife
does too and suddenly you come home
September and you say honey I quit how
do you deal with that how did the two of
you come at that how do you do with that
puts a story there well you know I think
it's um you know I think well you know I
I i think the Sal before marriage and
before son would have been much more
obsessed with kind of keeping up with
the peers in terms of lifestyle and all
that but you know I think I think once
you you know what when I really
seriously introspect on where I find joy
in my life it really does not come from
you know I mean we're not living like
pot you know I had saved enough from for
my hedge-fund days I mean I'm but not a
lot from by Valley standards but enough
for me to not feel like living off of
savings for a year was going to kill us
or prevent my kid from going to college
or anything like that so I'd saved
enough there and you know we live in a
in a you know 2,200 square foot house in
a nice part of mountain view which is
not you know the fanciest neighborhood
but it's a really nice neighborhood and
it's the weather's good and do you have
to convince her did you have to explain
to her listen I gotta do this or did she
understand she know you know it well I
think what a couple of the first few
iterations when I thought about it she
was very like wait you're gonna give up
that job where you know every year
you're making fifty percent more than
the year you made before your you know I
mean the thing about these careers like
hedge funds or banking or is that they
say well you know hey stick around next
year and you're going to make more than
you made the last five years combined
like gee that's you know maybe I should
she's like your energy my wife is not
materialistic at all but it for anyone
it's just like gee that would really
like not only allow us to Mia we could
buy a nice house and then we could even
support our parents and I mean there's
all sorts of things you know you can
always think of more things to do with
resources but when you really kind of
sit down and think about you know I used
to play a game with a lot of friends
like how much is enough right like how
much it like what do you need so that
you really don't need and everything
above that it's just gravy and some type
of competitive whatever you know who
knows and you know people out here they
throw out five million 10 million 15 I
mean you know and that's way above
enough I mean you know for me enough was
was below seven figures and so I i I'm
not taking a salary with Kahn Academy I
quit my job convinced that like GM I'm a
complete dummy if I don't commit someone
that this is the highest return on
social investment I mean for the cost of
a preschool we can be educating millions
people for all of time it's not even
like a school where if the funding dries
out that the school disappears know the
content will be there it'll be there on
itunes and youtube forever and so you
know I I was like gee I gotta be able to
convince somebody and it is kind of and
you know being in the valleys been a big
benefit there because I think people
here more than anywhere one there is
capital people have resources and they
see that they don't that you know they
don't they're not as swayed by the
touchy-feely you know a nice picture and
and you know please give some money and
help you know that they understand
things at scale they understand when
there's when there's something that has
broad impact and they understand return
on on investment and so um yeah I mean I
kind of veered off track a little bit
but I think the simple answer is I got
it I had enough and that not enough was
below seven figures but enough that I
could put a down payment on a on a four
bedroom house in mountain view we have
you know two relatively new hondas and
and I'm now able to take a salary from
Khan Academy doing exactly no I tell
people if I had if you wrote me a check
for five billion dollars five years ago
I would have probably bought a house may
be a little nicer than this house but I
would have but my day limit of its would
have been spent making you
videos they wouldn't have changed and
now I get to do it anyway and so so you
know why chase the five billion dollars
which already would have a low
probability of happening anyway and I
probably just end up you know 40 or 50
years old just probably with some amount
of money in my bank has a safety what
have I done like I haven't had you know
now konica me every day I'm excited
about what I've asked yeah I did these
videos kids are already watching it this
is tourney good gaining momentum and
concern into a new type of school I mean
it boggles the mind i tell my wife every
damn i mean literally every night I'm
boggled by how fortunate I am that this
like wide open opportunity to do
something really big it's just there and
no one's been doing I mean and I'm want
more people to do it I don't want it to
be like you know only salvage this wide
open opportunity to really change things
that all the technology is kind of fall
in place and and I think the way to do
it is that on a not-for-profit because I
think that's what allowed all of the
inertia and the goodwill and actually
kept me straight in terms of my goals I
think if I did it on a for-profit basis
very quick quickly I'd be like oh in
order to monetize it I have to go to
this part of the market after get 90 and
I start charging for some part earlier
than I should and that people wouldn't
even learn like you experience the Khan
Academy videos see well that's a really
good video and if I put even a 50 cent
barrier on that video you would have
never experienced it and for me that
would have been fun you know I put this
way if I had if I had a million 5 10
million dollars in the bank and you know
and 5,000 people watching these videos
vs I have a hundred grand at the bank
and 50 million people are watching the
videos that is a much more satisfying
outcome for me than the former so that's
why I'm doing it like this oh this is
incredibly inspiring story we'll leave
it there I grateful to you for coming
here and doing this interview I know you
probably could've whipped up five
different videos today for konica I
don't have to catch up now all right I
have to catch up now you have to catch
up now a few people as we were talking
came up with suggestions for what you
should do to tweak your youtube video
channel to get more viewers are you I
couldn't I couldn't understand it well
enough to explain to what they were
suggesting are you open to those
suggestions should they email you
directly yeah well you know there's a
couple yeah they should email salad
khanacademy.org um
and you know the the software piece is
an open-source effort and a few
developers who started working on
anything they've been rock stars and I'm
very open they're like hey you know your
knowledge map that you drew out it
should have arrows instead of Arc's
because you know that's again they put
arrows in there so I I'm a big believer
and put stuff out there and I'd rate and
keep repeating as quickly as possible
and and and and it should as long as the
people hydrating it aren't doing really
silly things it should move forward well
thanks guys if you have any feedback any
suggestions want to be a part of this in
any way saw Sal at Khan Academy com
00080 right salad khanacademy org but
you also have the dot-com no I don't
somebody all shine.com I don't own the
dot-com who is the evil son of a [ __ ]
who has the dot-com who does not know I
don't know yeah no actually came off of
like I almost was able to get and then
someone got I don't know I there people
more sophisticated it at squatting
domain names than I am I guess so
somebody get that domain back form if
anyone out there is listening get that
domain back all right thank you in all
seriousness thank you for doing this
interview and I'm really looking forward
to this weekend watching your videos oh
great thanks a lot cool bye